they sent me over the first eight
episodes of season two
of course i watched all of them your
character of ed uh
he has a lot going on this season yeah
yeah for fans of the series
what are you allowed to say you know we
come in 10 years after the end of the
first season and you know the the cold
war
is now boiling hot uh
space is the primary arena and
but you know for ed he has uh he's
initially he is taking a step back and
um you know of course
you know the last time we saw him he he
came off this
ultimate tragedy that any father can uh
can experience
but i think that at least initially it's
uh
it's it's you know it's a different ad
that we meet and um
and i mean when i first read it i was it
was all i was almost provoking you know
like it seems like he's
happier than before he's like all this
he has this lightness and
jokingness to him but i think that's
that's uh
you know very much of the sophistication
of of the writers of this show that
you know they they take it one step
further they they think it through one
one step further this is
ten years after that tragedy has uh
has happened and um so it you know it it
is a new ad but
you know space is always going to be
calling and um
and and he is going to be at the center
of things when
this cold war uh reaches a boiling point
in space
that's a very good way of selling now
that i've seen what's happening
you did a very good job without saying
without revealing too much
um thank you i've done this a couple of
times you know
exactly would you see in the script that
your character is going to be eating
spaghetti and drinking
and you know that this is going to be a
day of eating and drinking
are you like god damn it because those
have to be a pain
to shoot yeah so you know a couple of
things there
um so a rookie actor
um comes into an eating scene
a little hungry right before lunch you
know and uh and then you know first take
is like you know what i'm gonna just
take a big chunk of this
you know spaghetti because like i'm
hungry and um
and then you know it takes a bit he eats
you know you shoot the master first
right
so so then he just you know he
establishes that this guy just golfing
down food
and then they say cut all right lunch
and then and then you go to lunch
and and you get your trailer and you've
already ordered you already put in an
order for a food and
you already ate a bunch of pasta but you
know
it's it's kind of delicious the food
that you get in your trailer so you
still eat a little bit more of that
and then and then this rookie goes goes
back to set and it's like
okay now we're going to do this you know
in another
five to ten different setups and you
have to
you know you already established the way
and the amount that you're eating
so you have to eat that way for every
take for every setup
so you know that's that's what that's
what a rookie actor does
um and me
who's been doing this for 20 years but
for some reason that's what i did during
this puzzle scene and uh i think i think
we counted that i
ate like 12 plates of pasta like 12 full
plates of pasta over this it was over
10.
um i also have an enormous capacity for
pasta
it's just uh it's just one of those
things that i i do
really really well i can only imagine uh
what you felt like that night
yeah no there was a there was a couple
of natural disasters that took place and
those poor guys you know those poor guys
that
that that clean up the trailers at the
end of the day
and uh i mean just the
horror the horror yeah they need to they
need to be paid
they you can't be paid enough really you
can't be paid enough
not the way i expected to go but i love
the story
um there are a lot of great story lines
in season two which was your favorite
besides your own
oh i only read my lines
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] my
line my line my
[ __ ] [ __ ]
no i i think uh for me i thought karen's
story line karen so
baldwin my character's wife
you know we're we have very you know
there's very separate things going on
apart from our lines but but
her her character's journey is i think
the most surprising
and original and uh
just epic um the path that they take her
character on
is really really interesting so yeah
i completely agree watching it there are
some
twists and turns that i did not see
coming it's uh the writing is kind of
good
yep yep um so talk a little bit about
uh you've worked on a number of
different things
what what do you think might surprise
people to learn
about like the behind the scenes of the
making of for all mankind is there
anything
that like really impresses you about
what how they make the show
it's just one of those those projects
where things just really come together
where where you just feel like the the
writing is really good
the people uh that are involved are
nice good people so there's like a
really warm
and creative culture on set
and um
yeah i i i don't think it's anything
really surprising i mean
sometimes i get i get surprised by the
scale of it
it just this the set builds are you know
increasingly uh impressive and
um you can really feel like there's a
lot of money
being put into it to make all the
details it's
uh like the set the set decorations are
incredible
and um and we just you know we have um
you know the top shelf expertise of
you know former nas uh
spacex flight director and you know that
are they're
involved in in just like making all the
details right and because we're you know
we're both
inventing new things right but also
being historical so it's that going back
and forth in between those
so i don't know if there's something
that really surprised me but um
uh but there's a lot that amazes me i'm
so happy that the series got picked up
for season three
and uh i love the fact of where this
show could possibly go
have the writers told you anything about
season three
um are you you know what do you know
stuff
i know stuff i know stuff steve but
i can't tell you i can't tell you yet
um no no it's um
what what i love that now you know in
the second season i mean
you tell me if i'm wrong but when when i
you know with what i know about the
grander vision of this show and where it
goes over
you know not three but you know four
five six seven seasons
um it
i find it really exciting that now in
the second season you start to
get an inkling of the grander vision of
this show
and you know in the third season you're
really in
the thick of it but but this show you
know it starts kind of small
almost sort of you know like a madman in
the nasa
world and then it goes off on this
alternative timeline but we're still
sort of
in the realm of what we sort of knew
about that time and then you know of
course then we're establishing moon
bases
and these things that haven't happened
but then in the new 80s we're really
we're seeing this shift the divergence
of the two timelines and
and that this alternate reality is now
becoming more much
you know more dynamic and a lot more
things innovation has really
increased but over the course of you
know as the seasons progress
we really start going further into space
into more sci-fi territory and and
that's
you know we're starting to see that
build happening it you know it's a
it's a slow gradual build to get there
and um
uh but it's uh i i love how this
how this show the architecture of this
show is being built
and um yeah so it's it's really exciting
to
to know that we're going to get to show
that to people
yeah i i obviously haven't seen episode
9 and 10 yet so i don't know how the
season ends and i don't know if there's
a
another 10-year jump before going to
season three because exactly
depending on how that goes because i
asked the right coins
bitcoin as
i i asked uh the guys what season will
we see like a starship um and they just
laughed
because i'm like it's coming they're
building towards it you know this is
you know yeah
okay i gotta stop um hey listen man
congrats on on the show
i'm a huge fan and i'm so happy you guys
got picked up for a third season
awesome dave always a pleasure talking
to you